Hello here again, Steve Kaufmann,
and today I'm going to talk
about pronunciation and cultures.
Should take my glasses
off I don't need them.
Remember if you need the...
if you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe, click on
the bell for notifications.
And if you're following me on a
podcast network, please leave a review.
So today I have the pleasure
of speaking with Iryna.
Now, Iryna has a YouTube channel, and I
will leave a link in the description box
and her background is very interesting.
She traveled from Ukraine to Mexico.
So as a Ukrainian, of course she
speaks Russian and Ukrainian.
She speaks excellent English,
but also Spanish as well.
I want to talk a little bit about that
journey to Mexico and she is now so
good at Spanish that she provides advice
and help to people on YouTube about
learning English and about learning,
uh, Russian and her pronunciation in
Spanish to my ears sounds very Mexican.
And I don't want to exhibit any
prejudices, but very often Slavic
language speakers seem to have trouble
speaking sort of accent-free...
that's a generalization.
It's not fair.
So I'm very curious to find out
how, uh, Iryna found herself in
Mexico and how, how come she speaks
such good Spanish and English.
Hello Iryna.
Hello, Steve.
How are you?
Fine thank you.
Sorry for the long introduction,
but I think it's going to be
quite interesting to our viewers.
First of all, what brought
you to Mexico from Ukraine?
Uh, so I moved to Mexico in 2013
because I met my Mexican right now
husband in that time boyfriend.
And so love brought me to Mexico.
Uh...
Often the case.
Yes.
And right now it's very popular.
These kinds of stories.
And my, and my life changed
like completely like completely.
Yes.
And when you arrived in Mexico,
what was your level of Spanish?
Zero.
So I knew before, uh, before I moved,
I traveled to Mexico several times.
Uh, I've been like six weeks and
three weeks and I didn't learn
really an, anything about...
in Spanish.
I knew like gracias, how are you?
Like all this basics, basic stuff.
And I moved and my goal
was to learn spanish.
You know, you told me
that my English is good?
Actually I all, all my life, I
struggled with learning languages,
any languages, English especially
because for me, it's like very hard.
I don't know.
Uh, so right now I think I learned,
uh, English actually, because I learned
Spanish in this point of my life.
Spanish is my like main language after
Ukrainian and Russian, of course.
Yes.
So, um, I, my goal was to learn Spanish.
I wanted to integrate to the culture.
I understood that, uh, Mexico is
a country with a lot of, uh, like
identity, uh, and I needed to learn
spanish, uh, to be part of this
country, to be a good citizen, you know?
And I learned, like I had several courses,
uh, there in the school for foreign years
and, um, um, I, I took it very seriously.
So many questions I have, but first
of all, you said that you think that
studying Spanish helped you improve your
English, did I understand correctly?
Yes.
I've had the same experience.
If you learn another language, you get
better at the languages that you are,
up to that point, trying to learn.
So that's very interesting to me.
Yeah.
It's like a lot of vocabulary is
similar and actually grammatical...
grammatical stuff also like "has
been" ... it's very similar for me.
English grammar was always very difficult
and, uh, thanks to Spanish grammar i, I
could learn some English grammar also.
I also think, but I have no proof
of this, that, uh, when we learn
languages, we require a certain
degree of flexibility in the brain.
And if you say, do different
sports, the more sports you do, the
more flexible you're going to be.
And I think the, the fact that even
of learning Spanish makes your brain
more open, more, flexible, more
capable of doing better in, you
know, language habits in English,
but that's, that's just my theory.
Um, so the second thing is you
said I'm going to become, so you
were very determined to be as
fluent as you could be in Spanish.
Now...
and I imagine that not every, I mean,
you're, you're married to a Mexican,
so I'm not sure you qualify as an
ex-pat, but a lot of the foreigners who
live in Mexico, they don't all commit
themselves to learning Spanish or do they?
Yes, of course.
Um, some of the people
I know, especially...
learning Spanish by Mexican
telenovelas, of course.
I...
it's not my approach because
I don't think I'm so good to
learn languages by listening.
So I need some classes.
Uh, well, my goal was actually after
I moved to Mexico to become a TV
host and I understood that I need to
speak like no accent, and everybody
told me like, it's not possible.
You always will have your accent.
So, uh, but at some point I became
so fluent that people like...
not only fluent, but the
question about accent.
So some people they don't...
they're Confused.
They think I'm, I was born in Mexico.
Sometimes they ask it's not, uh, just
because I want to speak about myself.
Like, I, I don't have any accent.
No, the accent is okay.
But for me at that point of my life
it was so important to, um, get
rid of my accent to, to be on TV.
And I want to pursue that dream and I,
I had the dream, so I really worked on
it in Mexican TV and, um, uh, Uh, for
me, it was so important that I did it.
So I don't know it was, it wasn't
my, like my, my cute idea, you know?
Right.
But part of it is that
you wanted to be Mexican.
You wanted to fit in.
And I think that's a very important
part of, of learning a language.
And it's a very important
part of pronunciation.
So if you, you want to be like
them, you want to be part of that.
So then you don't resist the
way they pronounce things.
You absorb the way they pronounce things.
You start to use their, their structures,
their, and their, their, their
phrasiology and all of these things,
because you, you sympathize with them.
You want to be them.
And I think that's a big part
of pronunciation and a big
part of language learning.
But you had a very specific goal,
which was to be on television.
So therefore I gather you actually
took some specific sort of
lessons, coaching in pronunciation.
Yes.
I had coaching of my
accent, for my accent.
I had a great teacher, actually.
She's very good.
She's uh, working with actors, uh, uh,
that are coming from different places.
And a lot of them are from Slavic
countries, which is difficult
to work with this, with us
because we have a lot of accent.
Uh, and, uh, I work like
for one and a half years.
Um, maybe like really, um,
working hard maybe for one year.
It was one class a week, but I had also
honework, I need to so the pronunciation
stuff, like exercises, working with
um, uh, with some stuff and, uh,
texts, uh, texts and all of that.
So, um, the...
I was just going to say what sorts
of things, like when you say...
I know a lot of actors and
actresses, they have accent coaches.
And we see movie actors who can, you
know, speak in different accents and
very well and so forth and so on.
But what did they do?
What specifics?
Like, what are the specific steps?
Instructional method?
The first idea that we need
to understand: what is accent?
Accent is three things, uh, the
vocabulary, because Spanish is
very different in all of the
countries, Latin America and Spain.
So vocabulary is different.
The second one, the, the phonetic, uh,
the pronunciation of certain, uh, letters.
Because in, I don't know...
I had problems with R and D.
It's different in Ukrainian  and Russian.
And of course, when you speak
about the Spanish of Argentina
or Mexico it's different because
in Mexico we don't say...
like, uh, we, we pronounce some
words differently and letters.
Yes.
Uh, and the third one is the song,
the melody that has the language.
Yes.
So actually the same in different, not
only Ukrainian, Russian are different
from Spanish, but also Spanish in
all of these countries is different.
Argentinian accent have their own song.
The Spanish from Spain is their own song.
So I very...
I like so much Spanish because of that.
It's so different in all of these places.
And I like to get to know people
from Bolivia or Venezuela, Colombia,
uh, I don't know, Spain, different
parts of Spain, Argentina  of course.
So, uh, what we do in our classes,
what we did is, um, I don't know,
we worked with um, one of the
classic, um, exercises is with a pen.
So you put a pen like this and
pronounce things, but, uh, this one is
a little old, old fashioned exercise.
We use the, how do you call from the wine?
... the bottle of wine.
And you have these,
uh, ... that you close the...
Cork
yes.
And you put it like this and,and
you start to pronounce this....
yes, pronounce, uh, the text,
um, we, uh, worked a lot with um,
texts that are oriented to several,
uh, to specific letters, yes.
It's R it's B O, uh, because
you know very well that in
Russian, we don't pronounce O.
But you do in Ukrainian.
Yes, we do in Ukrainian.
So I think that's why I think like
Ukrainian Ukrainians, they have more
possibilities to improve their accent
because we have more, um, we speak
both languages that are similar, but
they also have different pronunciation
and different, I don't know the
philosophy, the feeling is different.
So we have more...
I think Ukrainians speak two
languages so they're at an advantage.
The more languages the easier
it is to learn new languages.
For sure.
Now at your YouTube channel, you, uh,
teach English to Spanish speakers.
Spanish, no Russian, no.
Sorry.
Okay.
Let me, I mentioned this because I'm going
to make sure people go to your channel
to hear the interview that we just did in
Spanish so they can hear you in Spanish.
Because some people were asking...
probably saying themselves while I'd like
to hear you, you know, speak Spanish,
they can go to your channel and they
can hear our interview in Spanish.
But tell me, what do you
do at your YouTube channek?
Well, my, actually I started my YouTube
channel when I wanted to improve
my accent and improve my Spanish
because it's so difficult to, like...
you speak and you don't hear yourself when
you speak in your daily life, but when
you hear yourself speaking on camera, when
you see here, these recordings, you're
like, My accent is so strong, or I started
to understand my pronunciation, like...
mistakes that I make.
It was actually one of the exercises that,
uh, uh, helped me improve my Spanish.
So I started my channel to be, uh,
on, um, to have followers to grow, uh,
that people can see me or that I can
work later on TV, uh, also to practice.
And I started to share my
life as a Ukrainian in Mexico.
Do blogs.
Um, uh, speaking about my journey, how
I learned Spanish, because a lot of my
followers are from Mexico and they want
to know how did you learn Spanish so well?
Can you help us to, uh, to learn
another language, especially Russian?
I saw a video of yours where you were
talking about pronunciation in English
so I had assumed you were also helping
Mexicans learn English, but it's
more Russian or languages in general.
I also promote to learn English
because English is very important
for career, for our travels.
Of course it's important.
Uh, but mostly what can I
help...uh, I can't help with,
uh, accent in English clearly.
Uh, but, uh, what I can help with
is, uh, uh, like a motivation to
learn language, wherever you want.
I always say that you need to learn
a language that you want to get to
know, you want to get to know the
culture of this, uh, uh, country, uh,
uh, because it's so important for me.
It's like, uh, uh, learning Spanish from
Mexico is, it's incredible because I
got to, uh, learn the history of Mexico.
They're famous people.
Um, the Mexican culture is so rich, so
it's incredible to learn another language.
It gives you a lot of knowledge about
history, culture, people, and all of that.
You know, I, I couldn't agree more,
uh, we'll leave a link to your YouTube
channel in the description box.
And what you just said about
learning about Mexico and their
history and their culture is
exactly what I have experienced.
Whenever I have learned another language,
uh, you have more of a perfectionist
approach than I have had because you
had a professional reason, plus you're
living there, but it doesn't matter
what our goal is, but we want to
achieve perfection and get rid of our
accent, or simply explore the language.
Language learning is such a worthwhile
activity and, uh, so I think we're
going to leave it there cause we could
probably, we have so many things that
we agree upon we could speak forever.
Uh, but I would encourage people to go to
your YouTube channel and thank you very
much for taking the time to visit with me.